c'est lucio on y est comme promis
j'interviewe tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle et cette année
ça se fait dans un cadre très
particulier chaque candidat fait face à
un écran géant sur lequel défilent une
amoureuse des mots j à plusieurs
reprises en appuyant sur le buzzer il
arrête la roue sur un démo j dont la
face cachée révèle tour à tour une
archive un jeu une citation une carte ou
encore des surprises et c'est à chaque
fois le point de départ de question que
je poserai pour mieux comprendre sa
vision et son programme l'interview face
cachée c'est donc chaque jeudi et chaque
dimanche à 19 heures sur la chaîne
youtube principal hugh décrypte rendez
vous donc ce dimanche pour la première
interview d'un candidat